time to treat yourself ladies on this
international women's day
rocky theater showing us a local shop
that makes prioritizing self-care
sweet and easy hey rocky
so we took a bubble bath earlier as you
know celebrating international women's
day we all deserve
a bubble bath a sweet one at that don't
eat the cake though it's it's not cake
it's soap
all right so now my the advice that i
received here is when you take a shower
you have to scrub right absolutely that
is the key to a to an effective shower
apparently
you know after actually you know washing
yourself so let's talk about the um
mineral sea salt bath bar here that you
can enjoy you come in and you do a
custom
bath salt so how does it work so step by
step it's a custom build you can add all
of your salts
and then from here the next step that
we're going to do is we're going to add
our fragrance
it's going to be the honey honey oat
fragrance
i'm going to throw some in there do the
rest of it in there
and it smells so good you guys as soon
as you walk in it's just it just hits
you
and then go ahead and give it a little
bit of a shake okay perfect
it's like a little martini this is so
fun and obviously diy we love that
because
you can come here and get things
pre-made and made for us but you can
also get all these ingredients at home
and do it yourself
all right okay there we go once we're
done shaking we're going to add a few
more ingredients
okay i see honey i got some honey honey
in the scrub
so honey is going to soften and smooth
the skin i'm going to throw a scoop of
that in there
and then from there we're gonna add some
coconut milk
and what does that do that's a unique
product to put in a bath coconut
is very good for irritated skin
it's gonna help out with the irritated
skin and then also remove some dead skin
cells
oh and that's good especially nowadays
since most of us are at home
you only have you have to remove the
dead skin okay
for that smooth skin perfect beautiful
oh my gosh then we're finished
and then you just pour it in the bottle
and
and people can come down and buy these
pre-made right absolutely
that is delicious perfect
and after you do a scrub i learned also
that the key
is moisturizing of course moisturizing
have the answer
for us as well yes so we have cream one
um it's really unique it actually comes
in two sizes here
so we've got our large and our small i'm
gonna try it and then
here you go so what makes this so
special so
not just like a body butter it's
actually whipped up
a lot lighter and smoother can you hear
super bothering
this is amazing oh my gosh i can just
imagine this all over
this is self-care utopia
okay your sweet bubble bath infections
you guys i'm having so much fun and
happy international women's day
ladies and men too get into it take care
of ourselves
you deserve it